you know the question of say Monopoly  power is not necessarily a question of  the mere uh percentage of an industry  that accompanied one or two firms  controls but it's whether or not there  are barriers to entry whether or not  people can leave or whether or not the  the major firms are acting as if they  are under competition so you know there  are times you know standard oil at the  peak of its market share it was charging  the least in America anyway it was  charging the least for its product ever  uh so you know that's maybe that's not a  perfect outcome but it's a com it's more  complicated than saying any firm that  has 75 85 90 of a market should be  broken up by a government which is  acting in the people's best interests  oftentimes interventions into the market  are either done for Pure politics  reasons or they're being egged on by  competitors uh competitor firms and they  don't actually make consumers or  citizens or individuals any better off